je suis dans un monde ikea par le
générique et qu'on n'a jamais
l'empêchent aux non sérieux les
intrigues avec des jeux pourris qui
flotte avec défilant milon on arrêter ça
en 2012 oui mais tu es une boîte en
plastique et c'est celle qui fait la
voile salut salut insolent subi la
malédiction
tout le monde me voit chaque et déjà
mais j'ai jamais eu d'épisode à moi ceci
va les frères l'appareil mais tout le
monde le pas ce monsieur mérite
1 2 3 4
qu'est ce qui s'est passé pourquoi
l'image attend tout petit pourquoi s'est
déformée et pourquoi t'es moche et
dégueulasse et pourquoi quand je parle
fort le sont ils saturent
je crois qu'on est retourné en 2010 oh
[ __ ] ma voix merde fut ta merde ok tu
le veux ton test tu vas l'avoir c'est
pourquoi je veux cette tête
gonis deux sorties en 87 sur nes tiré
d'un film que la plupart d'entre vous
n'ont jamais vu ou ont simplement oublié
le jeu est un jeu de plates formes
classiques on y sent bien la patte de
konami puisque cette esthétique et
certains bruitages me rappelle fortement
tortues ninja la preuve c'est que j'ai
vomi
le jeu alterne globalement entre deux
phases celle vue de côté classique
plateformes et les phases en première
personne à la manière d'un vendredi 13
est donc votre but est de retrouver les
autres goodies et ce je veux [ __ ] mais
il est très bien c'est quoi le problème
je veux dire ok c'est extrêmement dur
surtout quand ils jouent enfants et le
jeu est assez confus parce que dans les
passages à la première personne tu es
obligé d'utiliser chaque item sur chaque
mur pour pas loupé un truc cacher
évidemment c'est super lent mais parce à
un bordel de merde mais c'est pas
mauvais jeu [ __ ] de merde tu m'as lui
le bouffon temps en temps voilà merci je
disais mais pourquoi tu m'as bien le
générique alors si je suis nerveux fait
peu chier [ __ ] je les monte en 20
minutes le générique et bien tant pis
pour toi tu ne retournera jamais en 2016
tant que tu n'auras pas tester un jeu tu
peux me remettre dans l'étagère s'il te
plait je suppose que j'ai pas le choix
qui est volontaire
je suis aussi aux moutons experts sur
megadrive sortie en 96 édité par abalone
connu pour x pert ce jeu est un spin off
the eternal championne challenge of the
darkside sur mega cd lui même une suite
de eternal champion d'un jeu de baston
relativement moyen sur megadrive on y
retrouve dans les deux jeux le même
personnage central shadow dont on
parlera plus tard et surtout un [ __ ]
de pavés de texte
hu mais les mecs c'est un jeu de baston
personne va lire ça
donc allez revenons à xpert alors pour
commencer l'histoire après leur
formation de l'union soviétique en 1995
un consortium militaro industriel à
renverser les gouvernements mondiaux
pacifique avec à sa tête trois pays
diabolique la suisse le brésil et la
corée
des pays pacifiques ce que nous voyons
mon frère crawl
bref pour contrer cette menace les plus
grands pays s'associent à savoir les
états unis le japon et les pays bas ok
alors qui a fait la géographie s'il vous
plaît et décident de former une alliance
qui aura comme non les initiales de
chaque pays et janus
c'est trop tard
deux noms bref le reste de l'histoire
alors en février 97 bla bla bla
mutuellement avant ces consortiums pour
mutualiser bruits couple aux cieux
ailleurs tout est veut
bref donc dans ce jeu on contrôle trois
personnages successivement alors déjà la
première shadowy à moto comme on parlait
tout à l'heure elle est japonaise elle
fait des arts martiaux et elle a des
talents de ninja
non non je vois pas quoi ajouter
d'achille à claudel une espèce de cyborg
donc je pas du tout envie de lire tout
le texte et zachary taylor qui a master
en sciences informatiques et mais [ __ ]
on le change et les intérêts donc on
lance la partie mais arrêtez je veux
juste jouer à un jeu je veux pas lire un
[ __ ] de romans temps surtout que tout
ce pavé là c'est juste pour dire que tu
doit activer les ordinateurs quelques
risques est-ce que qu'est-ce que c'est
mon imagination
ok on va dire que c'est mon imagination
on va dire que c'est le programmeur le
plus venir du monde
voilà bref une fois l'ordinateur activé
vous avez accès aux autres personnages à
commencer donc par shadow miyamoto
l'espion de sa cuti ce témoin maîtresse
oui on y va entre son look à elle et
achille qui ressemble à une espèce
d'obscurs héroïne de comics oublié
depuis les années 50 et qui en plus
visiblement une énorme envie de faire
caca ou alors qu'ils étaient chose pour
le plus gros tampon du monde je sais pas
bref donc une fois que vous avez accès à
tout le monde c'est l'heure de faire vos
premiers combats les ennemis sont
indiqués en rose sur la carte
wahou
on se fait tellement chic et [ __ ] non
parce que en plus évidemment je veux
dire je suis littéralement transporté
par l'ambiance sonore et la musique qui
me plaît tellement dans l'action des
combats j'ai même acheté le cd
soundtrack du jeu on écoute des fois
en attendant la journée les notes c'est
aime pas ça s'appelle télé pas branché
le gameplay des combats est tellement
raide que je dirais pas qu'il a été codé
par quelqu'un avec un balai dans le cul
mais par le ballet lui même enfin donc
vous avez un éventail de coups divers un
coup de pied coups de poing vous pouvez
aussi tirer à distance mais quand vous
avez la ressortie vous ne pouvait plus
bouger je mens est sérieux c'est quoi ce
rayon de lumière quand les ennemis
meurent là cinquante pages de textes et
ils ont oublié de préciser qu'il ya un
mec qui peut des intérêts les gens à
distance alors concernant le jeu basique
mais c'est juste maintenance et
entretien de bâtiments le jeu vidéo
je veux dire ce jeu ne consiste qu'en
une seule et unique action c'est se
balader dans le complexe prendre
l'ascenseur et réparer des trucs en fait
pour être plus précis le temps dans le
jeu évolue en temps réel et au fur et à
mesure que le temps passe des événements
vont arriver vous allez devoir remédier
genre attention il ya un problème de
crimes au quatrième étage un travail
pour janus attention quelqu'un a vomi au
6e c'était un travail pour janus et
comme le temps passe et que les
objectifs dont sont limitées dans le
temps genre il ne reste affiché que
trois ou quatre minutes et bien des fois
le temps d'arriver un objectif
l'objectif va disparaître oh là là mais
[ __ ] mais c'était pas assez mou comme
ça que vous me faites me déplacer pour
rien a plus brefs donc quand vous
arrivez sur un objectif pour l'accomplir
il faut piraté l'ordinateur
oui bonjour je vous appelle concernant
la facture de janvier
on se fait chier
voilà j'ai peu plus tard passé abel
super deuxième objectif maintenant
est-ce que vous avez pété un câble et
comme si ce n'était pas assez relou
comme ça déjà deux tu peux pas avoir
deux personnages au même étage mais
pourquoi [ __ ] mais elle pris de la
drogue les développeurs et samaa de
second oui mais en plus je crois que
certains personnages met beaucoup plus
de temps à reprogrammer les trucs tu
sais quoi ce jeu où tu attends tout le
temps [ __ ] je vais me connecter à
internet pour pirater le système
c'est pareil pour les ascenseurs sur
n'importe quel jeu tu appuies le truc
arrivé ici non l'itie pour attendre
mais cette technique de mer de là de te
mettre des pavés de texte pour te faire
croire que tu fais des choses
complètement différentes alors que c'est
toujours la même punch aux de même deux
types de missions les principales et
secondaires et c'est exactement la même
merde
les carreaux et sans braquer un laser
sur les nations unies fait toute chose
vous devez empêcher un tir de missile
thermonucléaire qui va détruire les
états unis et nettoyer mois ses chiottes
bon alors donc vu que le temps passe et
on l'aura compris parfois vous pouvez
avoir des personnages qui se font
agresser pendant que vous jouez un autre
il faut donc switcher pour revenir sur
le bon personnage pour pouvoir vous
battre oh mon dieu c'est jojo
l'aspirateur de feu d excuser moi j'ai
besoin de me tourner pour albert est
notre joueur
bon c'est notre meilleure arme oui les
ennemis sont pas hyper diversifié 1
on a les soldats masculins les soldats
féminin et les aspirateurs et les trois
ont à peu près la même intelligence je
veux dire bien que les ennemis soit
pourri le jeu est assez facile parce
qu'il n'ya aucune résistance en face
mais j'en ai vraiment aucune
enfin les ennemis tu regardes bêtement
sans agir dit se servir de leurs armes
attendre gentiment que les tue je dis
regarde le lui je bouge pas je ne touche
pas la [ __ ] de manette et ai réussi à
me louper donc pour les ennemis juste
les aspirateurs qui des fois sont un peu
chiant à combattre parce que mais
n'arrive simplement pas à les toucher
[ __ ] mais [ __ ] en plus mais merde
quoi je veux dire sur le respirateur et
devrait savoir gérer ça est là
l'ingénieur d'ailleurs on peut admirer
le souci du détail que les développeurs
ont mis dans le jeu et le faisceau
lumineux qui fut même pas le canon de
son arme
les problèmes de xbox [ __ ] l'animation
des ennemis quoi regarder les cheveux de
la demo et même les ascenseurs mais
[ __ ] oui
ça aurait pris 10 secondes à fermer une
porte ou à mettre une barre dessous ce
jeu ipu la flemme à tous les étages
hamelin vu que des programmeurs qui
s'appelle david good enough tu comprends
pas pourquoi mais c'est de la merde ce
jeu vous pouvez pas sentir ça comme ça
on se pose s'ils veulent éviter que des
nains bref alors donc après avoir fait
environ 50 aller-retour à tous les
étages pour pianoter sur absolument tous
les [ __ ] d'écran du monde
vous finissez la première mission en
environ une heure et quand je dis 1h01
ses 40 me de ca et 20 minutes de ça bref
le jeu vous donne un mot de passe et la
mission suivante comment ce volet c'est
moi deviner est-ce que ça aura un
rapport avec piraté les ordinateurs
cherchait dans la base de données blabla
de la nabe rendait le jeu [ __ ] la
mission 2 te demande de pirater des
ordis c est exactement la même chose et
en plus cela exactement dans le même
endroit à l'import basculement il ya une
différence sérieusement devinez laquelle
allez-y devinez laquelle
les parts de be mais si tu vis n'est pas
cette mission deux dans les 30 minutes
la base explosé c'est le game over
il faut tout recommencer mais c'est fou
que ce soit un jeu qui te demande
d'aller vite alors que le jeu est ultra
lent qu'est-ce que je peux faire là bas
les jeux plus vite mais je peux pas je
fais rien j'attends mais qu'est ce que
tu veux que j'aille plus vite dans un
jeu où 80% du gameplay c'est ce toucher
les couilles sur un écran fixe moi je ne
sais pas j'attends plus vite
ouais ça suffit ce jeu est une poubelle
trou et qui sent la pisse et le vinaigre
ce jeu c'est un des pires jeux que j'ai
vu cet art démission c'est ça moi
j'aurais pu regarder ce caillou pendant
des heures je me serais moins fait chier
le concept à entier du jeu c'est de
regarder des bars pendant des heures
mais allez vous faire [ __ ]
et c'est là de bar tu la vois côté mais
puisque c'est une vidéo a lancé nos
finir l'ancien aussi
qu'on est de retour en 2016 j'ai
récupéré ma voix eh ben je suis bien
content d'être revenu parce que mon les
intrigues à base de jeux pourris qui
flotte dans les airs bon c'est un peu
n'importe quoi quand même à l'époque
ouais c'est vrai rien à voir maintenant
en termes d'écriture de technique on a
vraiment franchi un cap
je suis d'accord